in this video we'll talk about basophil
and its role in immunity
basophil can constitute the minority of
the circulating leukocytes
in circulation we would find basophil
which constitute one percent of the
total leukocyte whereas neutrophil can
constitute more than 50 percent of the
leukocytes
basophils are generated in the bone
marrow everything starts from the
hematopoietic pluripotent stem cell
which ultimately give rise to the
myeloid progenitor and the myeloid
progenitor ultimately give rise to the
basophil
once generated in the bone marrow it
gets secreted into the bloodstream
basophils are non-phagocytic granules
and it contains several basophilic
granules which are stained bluish or
purplish in the h e staining
basophils are relatively rare but they
are very potent in terms of their action
basophils are mostly important for their
response against parasites such as
helmins this is how the basophil look
like in a microscope in a blood smear we
can see all the granules in in these as
these are
pink
as these violet dots and it kind of
obscured the nuclear view
there are a lot of surface receptors
present in the basophil which broadly
fall into the category of cytokine
receptors complement receptors and
chemokine receptors
question is how basophils can get
activated there are many ways such as
ige cross linking b cell super antigen
mediated activation complement fragment
mediated activation chemokine mediated
activation or lipid mediators like
prostaglandins can also activate
basophils once activated they are known
as activated basophils
so these activated basophils secrete
several molecules
among the molecules which are secreted
most important are heparin histamine 5ht
eosinophil chemotactic factor
major basic protein tryptase chondroitin
sulfate clp and several interleukin such
as il 3 4 and 13.
one of the major role of basophil is to
drive the differentiation of th0 cells
into th2 cells
basophil secreted il4 actually leads to
this differentiation process
basophil also secretes histamine now
histamine acts on the capillary
endothelial cells lead to a vasodilation
it also secretes heparin which can
prevent blood clotting
now basophils are associated with
several diseases like allergic disease
there could be autoimmune disease
or even cancer
allergic diseases like atopic dermatitis
asthma contact dermatitis
hypersensitivity all in involves
activity of basophil mesophiles are also
associated with bolas pemphigoid
then crohn's disease graph rejection and
lupus nephritis
it can also be associated with cancer
such as acute and chronic myeloid
leukemia
now basophil number increase is known as
besophilia where is a decrease in number
is known as basopenia basophilia is
abnormally high level of basophil in the
blood and it could be associated with
several pathological situations such as
myeloproliferative diseases
like
cml there could be other
myeloplastic syndromes there could be
inflammation which lead to an increase
in basophils such as ibd ulcerative
colitis etc
there are many allergies which lead to
increase in basophil number
so basophil number has to be correlated
with the clinical situation basopania
means deficiency in basophil or decrease
in basophil number it has been indicated
as a sign of ovulation
anyway there could be other reasons such
as hereditary cost
elevated level of glucocorticoids drug
induced reaction or many others like
anaphylaxis
so this is how normal basophil look like
and this is how too many basophils look
like in a slide when there is basophilia
so as per summary we looked at what are
basophils
and we found that they are a minority of
the leukocytes
they contain large granules which are
basophilic in nature basophils are
important for their responses against
helmins
we also look at how basophil took part
in immunity and how they drive the
differentiation of ph 2 sublineage
and lastly we looked at besophilia and
vasopinia and how basophil levels
correlates with several disease
pathology if you like this video give it
a quick thumbs up you can get more notes
flashcards etc in my facebook page and
also in my instagram page all the links
are provided in the description you can
support our channel in patreon or beam
upi also there is a super thanks button
just below the video you can click on
the super thanks and pay using
paytm paypal upi or many other payment
option internet bankings for
you can connect to me via social media
using all the social media links which
are provided in the description you can
follow the nerd medic channel for
exclusive medical related contents and
mnemonics all the social media links are
given as that in the description as well
if you have a suggestion don't forget to
let us know in the comment thank you